international development policy forging
partnerships around the globe in the
interview German International
Development Minister gat mala
administered adorableness present mr.
Miller president joachim gauck recently
gave a speech that drew attention around
the world he called for Germany to play
a bigger part in international politics
the foreign and defence ministers then
jumped on the bandwagon how does
development policy fit in deutschland
spilt international and germany plays a
strong role internationally we also have
a strong Chancellor we have a strong
economy and we're very involved globally
uber but the question is are we carrying
out our international responsibilities I
think we are the other departments who
had debated the Munich Security
Conference was about whether we should
engage more militarily I think it's
since being put into perspective we're
contributing in Africa with training
missions apart as Development Minister I
can clearly state that we don't intend
to send in troops and that policy will
stay in place newcomb friend said to
want a beber top table but foreign
policy isn't just about the military as
leaders never tire of reminding us here
it's about taking on more responsibility
don't development policy in foreign
policy go hand in hand awesome politic
meet the end weaklings predict a head
island for common development policy is
really taking on a new significance it's
having a Renaissance as the new minister
I'm really pleased to see that happening
in the it's clear that we're getting
more and more involved in an
international context but Germany makes
up more than one percent of the world
population we are facing global economic
challenges but there's also the question
of human survival in places like India
China and Latin America if these are the
places in which we have to engage for
live-ins frog dimension enjoyed and see
him we can get involved in these
countries and these regions
and we're already well represented in
them on here Muzzin burns anger she and
Yakunin be on zangoose Ian Anderson
starkad written common good I've just
got back from a trip to india in where
we've reached wide-ranging agreements on
development cooperation by trying the
upcoming gustafson harden for example
we're helping India to achieve its
climate gun is he mad silly we're doing
that by sharing modern technology
offering investment opportunities
supplying know-how and training and
providing a modern kind of development
cooperation agosto and design you'd
mentioned India the development aid and
the support there is essentially credit
that will be paid back in the long term
it's as though this is something
different from the classic understanding
of development work on music in each
break out Nick Nippon into clunky fear
i'm also not talking about development
aid many people still have this idea
from around 20 years ago that the
minister travels around the world
handing out money to finance
humanitarian projects putting warmer
that's not the picture anymore Sophie
Nancy on does it sneak murders Heidegger
bid the truffula economic cooperation
and development house means partnerships
on an equal level specially in emerging
economies it's not looking down from
above and saying we know better you but
offering our know how our capabilities
the things that make Germany strong
start markings but we do this especially
in the field of sustainable technologies
environmental technologies green
technologies technology on and we
subsidize investments there but on an
equal level as partners one new point of
focus is of course our engagement in
Africa Africa is the continent of the
future chasm continent that so-called do
equal partnership supply there you were
talking about newly industrialized
countries is Africa difference does this
turn voiture answered scums besandose
that's the German approach and it's very
much my approach Africa is a
continent on 100 times the size of
Germany Huron it has 54 states different
you have to look at each country
differently under Belton around the
world of too much emphasis is put on
crises in conflicts there babe pride of
course that is a dark side to Africa and
they're giving assistance will be a
hefeweizen but I was recently visiting
the African Union even when it comes to
conflict on Africans want to and can
solve their problems themselves saber
Rosen absol haven't they responded to
situations by sending in peacekeeping
troops we're going to support them in
naggisch did you happen to double but
Africans don't want us Europeans or us
Germans telling them what to do in
thuggin and this cooperation is
something we also put into practice when
it comes to development in 2 o'clocks to
summon up we don't take charge we look
for partnership on an equal level
partner shaft of armed career thus
Iceland de proyecto so when you launch
projects do African partners have input
the chance to say this is what we need
how exactly does this kind of
cooperation work yeah softly meter
number yes we work together like I said
African nations are different when it
comes to development and their forward
momentum we have several points of focus
I was also recently in Ethiopia another
30 point one priority is fighting
poverty in those countries where there's
an urgent need to do circles the North
Kiptyn thin Petrovna Glendon we weren't
together to increase agricultural
productivity in the next two years i'm
going to set up ten new projects in
Africa that we look into how we can
increase the continents productivity
over the entire supply chain Amburg from
the field kill the way to the plank it's
some teller off titled the beauty probe
and we'll examine how we can make sure
the added value stays within a country
with the people Ivan Africa has the
ability to fill its own belly than the
and thrive the Sri appointed sistema 11
Spurs and other priority is providing
social opportunities creating jobs
especially for young African soch often
we have the best export in that regard X
training training training as it's been
especially professional training in
space ambra be roughly habido Aladdin
first act off mid we're going to step
off our outreach to German business
chambers of Industry and Commerce and
vocational training centres to invest in
the youth of Africa alkenyl also in
higher education and university
partnerships then Africa with all its
potential its mineral and human
resources will be able to solve its
problems on its own a property may say
about to be ready but come on to quote
something from your inaugural Bundestag
speech as Minister we want a
values-based development policy out of
ethical and moral duty of global
responsibility and also of national
interest what is Germany's national
interest in Africa deviating abundant
entwicklung sasame by the big run the
values based development cooperation is
grounded on modern humanism side in
Germany and in Europe you we're
fortunate and prosperous we enjoy a
wealthy economy we have good
infrastructure we who live in
industrialized countries consume eighty
percent of the wealth and the Natural
Resources the board ensures and we also
cause environmental degradation will
thaw we should and we must take on the
responsibility they need to help those
who don't yet have the level of
development that we enjoy both Leslie
have on patrol we should also do it out
of Christian principles and solid we
have to show solidarity and offer aid
and development cooperation but we also
have a national interest d quad who
believeth from diamond the key word is
human survival that's a pipe if we don't
contribute to solving dramatic problems
involving climate smog environment
problems in India or in China with
modern technology and those problems in
the form of climate change will come to
our door
I am a thief wat clima a hit song so or
not there are also humanitarian problems
and challenges probably me wouldn't just
think of the lamp a Doozer tragedy thus
trauma lumpy do saw the pictures on
television shook the world and it's over
and done with but the situation remains
for by uber the dramatic there are 50
million refugees in the world if we're
not prepared to offer them opportunities
at home they're going to head for the
rich countries Linda then via Nikki
rights and in Ananda layman's
perspective so how's it to people mmm
stating development cooperation is
always suspected of being partly about
promoting exports export promotion in
disguise what role does foreign trade
play in this sense soft technican didn't
to someone investments muslin signet
Willie Horton struck what investments
have to be worthwhile to a certain
extent we're not thinking in the short
turns though Germany wants long-term
partnerships and win-win situations it
rots Yonan via Guillen ethnic Africa or
Donna harzianum we're not going to
Africa or Asia today short-term business
deals our ministry doesn't support that
we see the long-term possibilities
unfolding we see the results of
contributing investments in relevant
countries that will lead to profit and
jobs in the medium term see her on phone
abbotsford simple wooden spy problem
Zevon before taking on this role of
development minister working on
development cooperation you were in the
agricultural ministry so in a sense you
are working on the other side after Alan
died together but at the moment of it
Isaac Roush top-secret IAM as
agricultural secretary i was able to
achieve these kinds of win-win
situations we succeeded by using modern
know how we brought in our agricultural
and biological engineering indigenous
crops investment in training with them
in the planet is capable of feeding 10
billion people systems provided we use
our knowledge on other continents as
well as on this one
re number incontinent unbidden latest
project will you hold on to sean is
there a success story you want to share
with our viewers Ganga fork from Lincoln
co-led humanity and definitely the
humanitarian and social goals we're
reaching together with our aid agency
partners I'd stress the issue of health
we still have problems in fact we've
made huge strides not before probably
Melbourne we have to say that when we
look at Africa polio has been
practically eradicated through the
magnificent work of the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and other organizations
doing great work good shift on but also
because of the development aid provided
by States but there's still a great deal
to do in the area of health is one that
spoke mr. Miller thank you